let's go to zach in cincinnati ohio zach
what's going on
uh um not much man just uh working on
living the dream i guess there we go
so what's up man how can we help so
a few months back uh i
bought a thirty thousand dollar car
um basically just because i needed
something that was good for the winter i
had a real wheel drive sports car
so i bought a four-wheel drive 2017 jeep
uh 29 000 in debt i work full time and
make about 13
an hour i'm a full-time student but my
school was paid for
um so my mom kind of said hey let's buy
this car and then you can just use the
ramsey pen to pay it off but after
watching more of the content on youtube
uh yeah that's not the ranking plan yeah
we are not
fans just like we should clear this up
for everybody parents included we are
not for you buying a car and then using
the debt snowball to get out of it
it's not a it's not a one-two punch it's
kind of hey
you know what high-five your mom well
played on her part yeah nice move mom
yeah so what's your question i guess my
question is
i looked up the kelly blue book value uh
it's like between 25 and 27
i owe 28 currently should i
at this point just sell pay down to the
value and then sell the car
or because i can do that at the moment
um or should i
just try to take this that snowball
approach to it give us the numbers when
you say you can pay something on it
what's that number
so i can put probably about twenty eight
hundred dollars on it this month
to get me down into the range of the
kelley blue book value uh i make sixteen
hundred dollars a month
roughly i could make more and work more
and get another job over the summer to
help pay the car
off yeah um but like just off of what
i'm going off of now i make about 1600
a month i have 500 car payment yeah well
so it's kind of a both hand so here's
what i want you to do uh you you need to
uh put the 2800 on it uh but you need to
be working
extra hours you can do that now you're a
young guy just go go
go go let's pay more of this down uh so
that when you sell it you've got
something
you you've got something to play with so
you can buy a car that's you know four
or five thousand dollar car that'll
easily take care of you
yeah and and zach i'd i'd even go one
step further i would
see if you could list this thing
tomorrow and see what you can get for it
and if you can end up um i don't mind
you taking out a small loan to pay the
gap off
and taking that 200 bucks and going to
buy yourself a car with cash
a beater car and then working really
hard to get that
small loan paid off because you're going
to go from i know it sounds weird for
somebody on dave ramsey tell you take it
alone but you're going to go from
owing what 25 000 on a depreciating
asset to owing
let's say you get 26 for it there's a
sucker somewhere and you're gonna owe
that two thousand dollars you're gonna
take that 2800 you're gonna pay that two
thousand dollar gap and then you're
gonna save up a little bit of money and
then buy yourself a car that's gonna get
you to and fro
you got no business man being in a
twenty five thousand dollar car making
yeah um 1600 the only thing i'd say is
if you do john's plan you got to have a
car or you're going to have to plan to
somebody you're borrowing a car so you
if you need transportation
uh there's a couple ways to get this
thing knocked out but knock it out very
very quickly
this is not something i want to take my
time with this is let's let's knock it
out quickly get yourself
a much cheaper car and start building
back
yeah i had i had five thousand dollars
saved up on it and truth be told i
thought it was a bad idea but i seen the
jeep and then got kind of like hey
listen don't beat yourself up we've all
had that happen at some point in our
lives where
you know the car looks really shiny and
it starts to whisper pie me by me
hey man you know and and if you get out
of life with a
your stupid taxes four dollars three
dollars a year
come on man decision tax is three four
thousand bucks
man you've won our dave talks about his
his stupid taxes had multiple commas in
it so you're good man you're good
learn this lesson now as a young man and
then move on man you're never gonna do
this again and you've got a bright
future ahead of you